جديد الوضع الميداني مع مراسلينا من مصر
مع رانيا الدريدي ومن نوفو غرب ضخمه جزيره
مع مراسل الجزيره حسن مسعود حسان نبدا معك
حيث انت في الميدان جديد الوضع واين تتركز
الان المعارك وفي اي جبهه
نعم عبد الصمد خلال الايام الماضيه كنا
نلاحظ تحليقا للطائرات المقاتله في سماء
المنطقه الجنوبيه الغربيه لمنطقه بخموت
وكانت تتجه نحو منطقه باخمه الاغاره على
تلك المناطق كنا خلال اليوم الماضي رصدنا
هذه الطائرات بكاميرا الجزيره ولكن اليوم
اعلنت الكتيبه 93 عن اسقاطها لطائره حربيه
من طراز سوخوي 24 فوق سماء مدينه باخموت
والطيار الذي كان يطير بهذه الطائره
استطاع ان ينجو عبر فتح المظله والخروج من
الطائره الفيديو كان يظهر
احتراق هذه الطائره
وسقوطها نحو الارض في محيط منطقه باخموت
وقد كذلك نشر هذا الفيديو رئيس مكتب
الرئيس الاو
وعلق عليه بان هذه الكتيبه استطاعت ان
تسقط هذه الطائره التي كانت تهاجم منطقه
بخمت هذا تطور ايضا في العمليات في منطقه
بخموت نحن كنا عندما ننظر الى هذه
الطائرات نستغرب ان هذه الطائرات تحلق
بشكل متواصل وبشكل لفتره طويله في سماء
المنطقه كما في ذات الوقت ايضا هذه
المنطقه التي نقف فيها هنا هذا الطريق
الفرعي كما تشاهدون ما زال الامداد
العسكري نحو منطقه بخمه مستمر من قبل
القوات الاوكرانيه يقدمون الدعم العسكري
وكافه المستلزمات للمقاتلين الذين ما
زالوا يتواصلون
وما زالوا في منطقه بخموت يواصلون القتال
وهذا امتثالا لقرار الرئيس الاوكراني مع
قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه بمواصله القتال
في بخموت وذلك بعد ما قال الرئيس
الاوكراني انه اطلاع على مسار المعارك في
منطقه بخمت هذا كله يشير الى الواقع هناك
الى كيف تسير الاوضاع عند تلك الجبهه
المشتعله ولكن في ذات الوقت فاننا نلاحظ
ان القوات الروسيه تقوم بالقصف بشكل مكثف
باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه والغربيه الجنوبيه
وذلك في محاوله للسيطره على هذه الطرق طرق
الامداد الفرعيه كما كانت ايضا تسيطر
ناريا عبر القصف المكثف على طريق الرئيسي
الواصل ما بين مناطق دوناتسك ومنطقه
المشهد الميداني في موسكو رونالد ريدي كيف
يبدو
او بالاحرى من موسكو
نام عبد الصمد يعني الجديد
نعم عبد الصمد يعني الجديد هو ما تم
الاعلان عنه قبل قليل من قبل مالك شركه
فاقدر يفرجن الذي اكد على اتمام قواته
للسيطره على منطقه
فضلا عن ذلك المصادر العسكريه الروسيه
كانت تتحدثت صباح اليوم عن سيطره قوات
فاجنر على المرتفعات الاستراتيجيه ليس فقط
في منطقه زليزان التي سيطرت عليها قوات
فاغنر بل وايضا في منطقه اريخ التي تقع
شمال غرب فضلا عن ذلك هناك تقدم لقوات
فاغنن في مختلف المحاور في مدينه الحديث
يدور عن السيطره على عدد من
على عدد من الاحياء السكنيه في منطقه التي
تقع في جنوب مدينه فضلا عن ذلك ووفقا لما
اكد عليه امس
تستمر المعارك في قلب في مركز المدينه
بالقرب من المبنى الاداري كل ذلك يعني
ياتي عبد الصمد بعد الاعلان امس عن سيطره
قوات فاجنر على احد اهم المصانع في مدينه
باقمت وهو مصنع
الذي يقع في المنطقه الصناعيه ازوم هذا
يعني اود التذكير ان هذا المصنع ذاته الذي
كان قد زاره الرئيس الاوكراني قبل نحو
شهرين وكان فيه قد يعني سلم الاوسمه
لقواتها العامله في باخمت وهذا المصنع بات
حاليا هو الاخر تحت سيطره قوات فاجنر من
جهه اخرى كانت هناك تصريحات قد صدرت من
قبل مستشار القائم باعمال رئيس جمهوريه
دانيسك
يانج جين الذي اشار الى ان هناك وحدات
متناثره من القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه
تنسحب بشكل دوري من مدينه باخمت وكون كل
الطرق الرئيس في هذه المدينه باتت تحت
سيطرت وقصف القوات القوات فاجنر فان هذه
القوات تحاول الانسحاب عبر الغابات
والارياف
وبسبب وبسبب الوحل بقدوم فصل الربيع فهذه
القوات تضطر لترك كل المعدات والاليات
العسكريه وبذلك تتكبد القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي تنسحب لا سيما خسائر
كبيره خلال عمليات الانسحاب فضلا عن ذلك
منذ صباح اليوم كانت هناك ايضا معطيات
تؤكد على ان القوات المسلحه الروسيه تتقدم
بشكل كبير في محور ام في محور كوبي عفوا
وفي هذا المحور تم السيطره على المنطقه
الصناعيه بشكل عام لو تاخذه لو يعني اخذنا
تصريحات التي صدرت قبل قليل عن وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه فهناك خسائر كبيره يعني
يمكن القول انه رقم قياسي خلال الشهر
الجاري
من حيث عدد خسائر القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه التي وصلت الى نحو 600 عسكري
اوكراني وذلك خلال 24 ساعه اشكرك
كما اشكر حسن مسعود مراسله جزيره من نوفو
غربا